in a desperate and pathetic attempt
to shift the blame texas republican
politicians
and right-wing media figures are lying
to their own residents
and to their audiences and claiming that
green energy and windmills are
responsible for the tragic power outages
that have been taking place in the state
of texas in the midst of
unusually but not completely unexpected
cold temperatures there and the reason
that they are so desperate to lie about
this
is that it's not just a matter of
accountability for the fact that there
are now millions without power and
without heat in texas
during some of the coldest weather that
they've seen in a long time
but their entire political ideology is
tied up
in government doesn't really need to do
stuff meaning
infrastructure spending green energy is
bad their entire ideology
is crumbling and so now they are telling
the lie
that windmills are the reason that
what's going on in texas is now taking
place and these people include
republican
governor greg abbott not telling the
truth it includes
tucker carlson it includes many others
the problem
in texas is not wind energy and we're
going to go through it today
and out of this tragedy there is the
opportunity to inform
about what happens when you ignore
climate science so here's what's going
on
more than 2 million people are or have
been without power in texas why
extremely low temperatures and snow are
affecting the texas
power grid now republicans are saying
the problem is wind power here is tucker
carlson making the case
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday well the
green new deal has come believe it or
not to the state of texas
and we're here with the report how's it
working out so far well the good news is
all that alternative energy seems to
have had a remarkable effect on the
climate as intended
last night parts of texas got to
temperatures
that we see in alaska in fact they were
the same as they were in alaska
so global warming is no longer a
pressing concern in houston
we've solved that problem the bad news
is they don't have electricity
the windmills froze so the power grid
failed now there are two big lies there
the first is that cold weather in texas
disproves
so-called global warming this is an old
one
climate science predicts not just warmer
global average temperatures but
localized
record highs and record lows more
erratic weather what we would call
unseasonable temperatures high and low
so tucker's first point is terrible the
fact that it's cold
in texas doesn't disprove anything in
fact it's predicted by climate science
but second secondly excuse me tucker
says the reason for the blackouts is
that the windmills froze and this is so
so so not true as a reason for what
happened
and it's important to have the facts ice
has forced some wind turbines to shut
down that's true
but wind power is only between 10 and 25
of the texas energy mix at this time of
year
the majority of the outages were caused
by
frozen instruments at natural gas
coal and nuclear plants that were not
prepared for such
cold weather even though they could have
been
and again cold weather predicted by
climate science models for decades as
meteorologist quincy vigil pointed out
on twitter
the power outages in texas are in areas
predominantly powered by natural gas
this was not caused by going green
with some of texas energy supply
but republicans in texas desperate to
blame someone else
are blaming wind power here is
republican texas governor greg abbott on
fox news last night
saying what we're seeing in texas right
now is a preview of the green new deal
what good is it sean this shows how the
green new deal would be a deadly deal
for the united states of america
texas is blessed with multiple sources
of energy such as
natural gas and oil and nuclear as well
as
solar and wind but you saw from what
trace said
and that is our wind in our solar got
shut down and they were
collectively more than 10 percent of our
power grid
and that thrust texas into a situation
where it was lacking power in a
statewide basis
that was power that was spread out by
that ercot organization
or organization that you were talking
about and then here is fox and friends
this morning but he said for the first
time he's seeing a little bit of
california now
with what happened with the weather and
the wind turbines one of the things that
the climate denial
industry does is to sow doubt
and to claim that there are
controversies and unknowns where there
are not
this is a really old playbook it's
described in the book merchants of doubt
they did it with smoking when they
couldn't do it with smoking they shifted
to doing it with secondhand smoke
they did it with acid rain they did it
with the pesticide ddt
they did it with the hole in the ozone
layer they've been doing it with various
elements of climate change
create doubt and manufacture a
controversy where there isn't one
and i saw lots of people on online
saying i don't know you know there's
just
it's hard to know what the truth is
about what's going on in texas because
each side has their view
we're going to have to wait it's going
to take time to figure out what the
truth is about the role of
green energy or not and what is taking
place no
we have the facts making it confusing
is the playbook that they use a wind is
not even close to the main
issue and wind is actually outperforming
energy output expectations
for this time of year in texas blaming
the problems
of frozen instruments at coal natural
gas and nuclear plants
on wind turbine freezing shows two
things number one they're lying to you
and number two these are problems that
have been solved
in other states but texas has refused to
actually deal with it
if in texas they had accepted climate
science
they would know number one we should
expect more erratic weather
and because that can mean really cold
weather
it means that we should weatherproof
not only the wind turbines but the coal
plant instruments
the gas plant instruments and the
nuclear plant instruments many other
states have done this
listen it gets cold in wyoming and
montana they have wind power as well
there are known solutions to this we're
going to look in the next segment at a
report from a decade ago
based on prior power outages in texas
saying here's the things you have to do
to protect yourselves from this in the
future
extremely cold weather affects natural
gas and oil pipelines because it changes
pressure
it affects instruments at nuclear plants
this is not
uh uh this is not new information and
this is not unique to texas
texas could have chosen to weatherproof
not just wind nuclear and nuclear
wind nuclear natural gas which are
mostly their sources of energy but also
the wind turbines and texas
got crushed because its operators and
its politicians
chose not to be prepared for cold
weather that's the story now once people
the priority is getting people power
back
once people have power back and are safe
who is going to be held accountable for
this because there are people
responsible
let's talk a little bit about the
history of this story in texas next
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford i asked them to
be a sponsor because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden
underneath the buttons which actually
prevents the chest from looking weird
and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout